girl i've got to live life i need to
like live life
casey musgraves seems to be living life
with her new beau
it was just cute it was just really cute
in this new photo taken on sunday the
country star is snapped waiting for an
uber while getting close with her
boyfriend
dr gerald onowoha a physician based in
nashville
a source tells et that casey and gerald
are dating
and adds that the new couple met in
nashville and casey
she's into him the source adds quote she
likes that he is a doctor
and not very involved in the
entertainment industry but
that he also gets it i think anybody
that's followed me
you know would recognize that so who is
casey's new man
well she first sparked romance rumors
with the doc on monday
after she posted this photo on her
instagram story
and according to his linkedin page we
know gerald practices
internal medicine at hca healthcare in
nashville
a city where of course the country star
frequents
gerald is also the first person casey
has been publicly linked to
since her split from her former husband
musician
ruston kelly the couple filed for
divorce in july of last year
and it was finalized in september
following news of their split
both casey and rustin shared messages
supporting one another on social media
rustin assured his ex in august quote i
got your back
in february casey opened up to rolling
stone about parting ways with rustin
explaining quote it's two people who
love each other so much
but for so many reasons it just didn't
work
casey's most recent music release was
the soundtrack for the casey musgraves
christmas show
and one thing's for sure casey's fans
are hoping this new romance leads to
another album from the grammy winner
that's nothing you expect as an artist
but
it was really beautiful it's been a year
and a half since e.t last caught up with
casey
where she said she was on the lookout
for new inspiration
first and foremost i'm a songwriter you
know but it is fun every now and then to
be pushed outside of your comfort zone
and i was singing acting
dancing i'm a triple threat now just you
know
logged that away no it was really fun
but it was very challenging at times
i need to fill up the song bank again
i'm gonna travel for fun
for once like that's a novel idea just
going to a place and not having an
agenda like
i'm excited to fill the inspiration tank
back up you know because that always
that always serves me right whenever i
let myself pause take a second
i i benefit from that and that's kind of
what i need i love being at home
hanging out with my horse that always
gives me some ideas
[Music]